we could learn more about what's going
to happen with the johnson and johnson
coronavirus vaccine today
as you know it's been on hold after six
women got rare but severe blood clots
after receiving the single dose vaccine
one of those cases is from here in
southern nevada cdc the centers for
disease control its advisors are holding
a six-hour meeting to discuss the
situation
cbs news has learned the u.s could
decide to resume
use of the j j shot but the fda will
require a warning to go with it
but it's creating more vaccine hesitancy
around the country health experts say
though
we should worry more about getting
coronavirus than any side effects from
the vaccines
i think too many people may be scared
off by taking the vaccine they shouldn't
be but
perception is everything when it comes
to vaccine
now one of the women who developed a
blood clot after getting the johnson and
johnson vaccine is as we've mentioned
18 year old emma berkey she is from
right here in las vegas
she's a senior at coral academy berkey
is being treated at a california
hospital and has been placed into an
induced coma after
three brain surgeries